hey everybody I am back it's been a
while it's so great to be here with
everybody we were we were away we we had
our first vacation since December
because of coronavirus we there's been
nowhere to go so we've just been working
since December and we did a little break
it was excellent I'm glad to be back I
think my last stream was let me see here
how many days ago was it my on by the
way hello yeah okay here I am okay seven
I guess it's been about 11 days since my
last stream it's incredible and I know
that nobody missed me so the days just
flew by like that and it was people are
like didn't you stream yesterday we
really haven't been nobody's been
waiting around for the next stream I
guess is the point so I am back we have
a Kaylee Magga nanny press briefing at
the top of the hour coronavirus is out
of control Trump is out of control
I've already already recorded a full
one-hour podcast for you guys which will
be coming out in 3 hours two hours
something like that thank you welcome
puppy and Neptune and Miss midnight
beast for the welcome back twitch prime
subscriptions I appreciate that we have
oh [ __ ] my twitch prime numbers have
imploded because I haven't streamed for
11 days so it's good to be back and
thanks to any greenfield and everybody
Amy Guerra says via super chat howdy
from the kovat epicenter of america
we're going to get to that yeah I have
so much to catch you guys up on and to
catch up on I don't even know where to
start so I'll just sit here and do
nothing for a little while
no I'm kidding we are actually going to
do stuff and if Kaylee Magga nanny is
late as she often is will will actually
have plenty of time so okay let's let's
refocus
first of all coronavirus we are now at
three million cases it's an absolute
disaster in the United States
Florida regularly in the five digits
since we went on vacation Texas
regularly between four and seven
thousand new cases a day California
still up there
Arizona's an epicenter it's really
really bad now the good news is that the
death numbers have actually continued to
trend downward even as the case numbers
which you see here are trending up there
are five different possibilities as to
why this is I'm not gonna do one by one
now because I do them on on a clip later
today
oh thanks we have a hype train going I
see that and I appreciate that the five
possibilities are some states are lying
about deaths
there's the lag which has not yet hit
the states with a lot of the new cases
it takes about 20 days for people to die
so to speak as dark as that is so that
could be a reason doctors could be
getting it treated getting better at
treating patients now that we have more
experience there could be a less lethal
strain I'm not saying there's evidence
for any of these things I'm just telling
you what the different things that are
being said are as testing capacity goes
up people who are less sick are getting
tests so even though the number of cases
may be higher that may represent people
who aren't really sick or people who are
really young both of which are less
likely to ever die from the disease herd
immunity I see being mentioned by people
in twitch chat and with peace and love
were nowhere near herd immunity you need
70% infection for something with an R
that is where coronaviruses reproduction
rate is we're nowhere near herd immunity
and some possibility of a combination of
those people wondering what podcast I'm
talking about my podcast so on today's
David Pakman show audio podcast we do it
every day it's free to everybody you can
just get it on iTunes stitcher Spotify
Pandora
I Heart Radio etc etc we talk about all
we talk about all of that so those are
some of the possibilities that were sort
of toying around with so far bye if the
lag time between cases and deaths is the
explanation by Wednesday or Thursday we
should start to see these numbers see
the numbers are always low on weekends
because of reporting inconsistencies
these Peaks like the Monday peaks should
be higher
certainly by by next Monday we probably
see some increase by the end of the week
so we're going to keep a very very close
eye on that people wondering when
Kayleigh McKenna knee starts it's at the
top of the hour that it's scheduled for
1 p.m. Eastern 10:00 a.m. Pacific let's
see what else we have going on I'm
inconsolable is welcoming me back by
subscribing for the tenth month I really
appreciate that thank you so so much
it's great to be back we do have another
joke so I've we're just gonna do a
monthly chess tournament for now I may
actually be participating in something
chess related that would be very
titillating in a couple months I mean
I'm not going to talk about that today
but next Tuesday a week from tomorrow we
are going to have chess tournament
number three and wait is that right yes
okay you can sign up at leaches org
slash chess look at how sad this is I'm
the only player right now in my own
tournament it's so disgusting
we had 732 people play in my last
tournament and I want to have more so
everybody's welcome this is free I'm
selling you nothing it's just show up
and play Lee chess org slash chess there
we go
Mauro Wolff has joined us and we now
have two people who are going to be
playing this incredible tournament
Connor Easterday has joined and yeah
we'll check back in but you can you can
register now it's come I'm selling you
nothing I'm selling you nothing it's
just come participate in a community
event that's going to be fantastic
there's Green Party Trevor signing up
we've got four people
Dhar the hunter is now going to play
this is great we like it's just it's
such a great community building event so
we're going to be doing that Tuesday at
8 p.m. next Tuesday not tomorrow right
next Tuesday you know what I'm talking
about other super chats coming in Jakob
Ratner says have you heard about the me2
movement in the sports twitch community
specifically Smash Brothers no I have no
idea about that a czar says Michigan's
zero deaths yesterday Sunday July 5th
that's fantastic here in Massachusetts
we had a zero death day
last week which was great Ron says I
think Trump abandoned the economic
populist rhetoric this election because
he never meant it in the first place he
switched over to full racism yeah it was
it was a game from the beginning check
out my video about how populism even on
the Left has sort of smothered social
democracy and you can get bamboozled the
hell out of with populist rhetoric
because it's only rhetoric social
democracy is a set of policies we are at
a level for hype train and we have only
25 seconds left to make it to level 5 I
don't know if we will do it it would be
auspicious if we were able to do it on
this first stream back Simon 21 edges us
a little bit closer shadow apex has
signed up Huck he'll we've got about 10
seconds and I don't know if we're gonna
make it guys
I just don't know 5 seconds to go
we did it
I'm inconsolable coming in out of
nowhere with a bunch of gifted
subscriptions unbelievable
Giga Chad move from what I've read on on
in encyclopedias and medical journals
and Giga Chad is just what happened it's
very very good appreciate that very much
we did it friends we did it we did it
okay Pat low oh no let's see here hella
cool guy says my main account cannot
leave super chats with no warning you
got a contact youtube I don't know
anything about that
Pat Lopez has signed up Dominic
Richardson says should forego Rico or DC
become States I believe that the answer
is yes I believe that the answer is yes
on both for different reasons arguably
but yes treason Ramone has subscribed on
Pluto and
- oh I like that Dave damn you look good
today thank you thank you very much I
appreciate that
and Tristan Ramon says Bernie supporter
here voting for Biden thank you for all
you do David it is important work Thank
You Tristan
I very much appreciate that people
asking about my vacation I guess I could
show you a couple of vacation pictures
by the way people have been asking about
the garden tour I will do a garden -
right after this stream I will go
outside and do a full garden tour on my
Instagram account if we get to 25
members okay we'll talk about that a
little bit later but I will do it today
I'll show you a few vacation pictures
these are all on my Instagram as many of
you are familiar with here is whoa hold
on a second oh my god it's not gonna let
me here is me you know just digging up
sand at the beach I was in Martha's
Vineyard this was all very safe it was
an in-state driving vacation okay very
safe didn't leave the state didn't fly
anywhere went did did take a ferry but I
just sat in the car the whole ferry I
was at a restaurant which was outdoor
only reservation only masks required
until you sit down I'm at a beach there
were very few people on the beach I was
at another place where there was just
nobody I drank water okay I held the
puppy you know it was all completely
safe and and fantastic and so that was
my vacation and I will do the garden
tour I'm promising it today today if we
hit the member goal so we're gonna deal
with that very very shortly and it's
gonna be an amazing thing okay what else
did I have so I do have clips
Trump gave two completely unhinged
speeches I guess we're calling them one
on July third one on July 4th and I have
clips from them we're gonna have clips
of this later so I don't know how much
time we want to put into it but like for
example here's Trump glitching again on
Jefferson this was weird
Thomas Jefferson the shoulder goes
Thomas jeffer it's a weird it's a weird
thing that happens it's just it's all
really weird let's see
at one point Trump couldn't say
totalitarianism I think he called it
totalitarianism let's see that one
totalitarianism yeah at one point he
again did you Lysias s grant of course
the name is ulysses s grant trump can't
seem to get that one right yep then at
another point Trump struggled with
magnificent and with mountain that was a
weird moment let's see here
okay so there was that and then there
was one other moment oh this is from the
July 4th one wait a second where is it I
don't want to miss it okay here was it
Trump just started listing historical
figures and the crowd actually I mean it
was weird because the crowd started to
like it oh my god
the videos have not been playing this
entire time I'm such an idiot
oh my god what just I can't believe I
just subjected people to that holy [ __ ]
oh my god
Jefferson oh my god
I'm so sorry everybody I'm so sorry
everybody I've just been listening to
these I cannot believe I just did that
everybody cancel your memberships right
now it's over we just that I mean I
can't believe I just did that to people
okay please clip clip as much of this
stuff as you guys can because I think we
can get we can get oh my god I guess I
have to go back to the beginning I had
so much stuff playing for you guys holy
[ __ ] it's great to be back it's great to
be back my god I don't even know if I
should start over it's just God I'm in a
show I'm gonna go over I'll go back to
that I just I'm out of energy after that
I can't believe that Susan Feder just
signed up at joined pakman.com Thank You
Susan I appreciate that listen I I said
I was back I didn't say that I was at
full full capacity today I'm building up
to it let's go back to the clips okay
let's go back to the clips cuz I don't
want to okay let's do something else I'm
gonna show you guys I've been getting
requests from people god I'm about to
get cancelled I can't believe this Danny
Thompson says you asked about this
before your livestream hiatus to make
white lettering show up brighter on
YouTube comments you bold by using a an
asterisk at the beginning at the end of
what you want to bold welcome back David
okay Maddie I Stevie Dee says glad to
see you back
did any woodland creatures ravage your
garden while on vacation no the garden
is stunning what's going on Danny
Thompson says must not work in a super
chat but it does work Ken Clive says as
much as
I appreciate your criticizing Trump I'd
like to see more coverage on progressive
candidates in all 50 states they will be
important going forward Stoneskin says I
love it you're true-blue David and not
so common sense has sent a retraction
has retracted a message oh my god I
think people are selling Pakman stock I
can't believe it that was just so bad so
I've gotten a bunch of requests from
people to just show more of the memes
that viewers of mine submit to me so
I'll show you guys some of I'll just go
through a few things and going forward
if people want me I get stuff all the
time and people want to sometimes people
send in memes or funny images involving
the show and then they're wondering what
other people send in so if you just send
them to me the best way is probably
david at david pakman.com I'll show some
of them on screen so let's look at a
couple of them I've got a bunch of
images like this which have not really
been memed yet but this is from like
before my haircut and it was you know we
really weird things were going on and
there's a bunch of these source files if
people want to do anything with them
this was some somebody made I believe
this is an emote that someone wants me
to make one make an actual emote on
twitch but I don't actually know how to
do that so if somebody explains to me
how to do it I can certainly do that
this is the Beatles hair day from the
old studio this is a favorite I get this
sent from people a lot this this boy
this requires some explanation this was
back during when I really stupidly
covered this thing called gamergate
which went nowhere and was just
ridiculous and I in I hosted sort of a
debate between a porn star who has since
been arrested for alleged child sex
trafficking if I recall correctly she
went by the name of Sadie's Carrera
I believe her actual name is Mercedes
Smith and former football player Chris
Kluwe I hosted it today and people made
made this and okay so that's that's that
whoa zoom in that's crazy I don't want
that let's see if we can go to the next
one
holy [ __ ] oh there we go somebody made
this this was the Virgin kolinsky versus
the Chad Pakman
this was a pretty funny one and it did
well on our reddit we're friends with
Kyle it's just funny you know it's not
I'm not saying anything I'm not
endorsing the message here but this was
a pretty good one
children of the lie when I mentioned the
idea that I would do a cover or a song
collaboration with Sam cedar Anthony
Mellon Fantana and Steven Kenneth
Destiny's been held a second somebody
made this this would be our album cover
I don't know why I'm kind of placed in
this position I don't know why I'm that
I don't know what my face is on this
particular person but that was cool
so that's another one people did this is
David Stalin which isn't a bad one okay
I mean this is really funny although I
just don't even really get it because
I'm like very much anti Stalin I don't
know this was supposedly me as a faces
of meth only one month later my hair had
gone completely gray and I guess I had
bags under my eyes and all sorts of
other stuff so that was that and then
this I mean this I don't think this one
really requires much explanation we see
what other ones I have and this was oh
yeah from my Ace Ventura hair this is a
new one actually this is from like a
week or two ago Pet Detective that's not
a bad one this is me as Kyle kolinsky
this is my head and it's actually
beautifully superimposed on the Kyle :
skis body with the microphone not even
pointed at my face which is a good one
so this is actually not bad and then
that's it
okay guys very good so always feel free
to send means in never be afraid they
will they will be put to good use I
guarantee it my friends okay other super
chats that are coming in jessica mech
Minh says here is a coffee to wake you
up
who is pop says hey David what is your
field of education I have a bachelor's
degree in economics and communication
and then I have a master's degree with a
consonant
it's like a standard MBA concentration
in economics and entrepreneurship that's
my education not so common sense says
what's your thoughts on FEMA getting out
of the testing business you know I'm
still catching up on news I didn't know
that that was a thing I didn't know that
was happening so I'm gonna have to read
up on that and 121 click bezel says
Republican never maskers are missing the
hypocrisy of their claim of personal
rights isn't that the basis of
pro-choice and wouldn't wearing masks be
the true pro-life stance of course of
course if you're looking for consistency
from the right on the issue of the virus
and you're holding your breath you will
soon be out of breath I think that's
that that's the primary point that I
want to make okay let's do a couple of
let's see if I still have time I think I
do let's so let me do a couple of the
clips that before I had no audio for
from Donald Trump you want me to check
on the chess tournament let me do that
okay we have 12 people registered for
the chess tournament our our next chess
tournament is next Tuesday at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern Time you can register for free
at david pakman.com slash chess it's
completely free I'm not selling you
anything
we had 732 people play last time I just
want to do better than that
so register free at david pakman.com
slash chess okay so Donald Trump gave a
bunch of speeches over the weekend they
were crazy
here's Trump glitching on the word
Jefferson take a listen we're going back
to the beginning Thomas Jefferson a
great Thomas Jefferson Thomas Jefferson
a great Thomas Jefferson so there's like
a when he seems to glitch on the word
and his shoulder goes up Thomas jeffer
Thomas Jeffers berry a great common user
stuff
ok well pause that one Trump mangling
the word totalitarianism I'm playing
these again because they had no audio
the first time this is the very
definition
of totalitarianism totalitarianism also
still struggling struggling with ulysses
s grant pronouncing it you Lysias
alyssia's says grant abolitionists there
you go
and then here was when Trump started
just naming people just saying names
that was that was the part of the speech
at the country of Andrew Jackson
alyssia's s grant and Frederick Douglas
we are the land of Wild Bill Hickok and
Buffalo Bill Cody and then he did that
also this was July 3rd frump also doing
this on July 4th porch Washington Thomas
Jefferson Betsy Ross Alexander Hamilton
Benjamin Franklin boom take that bite
John Adams owning the lips
James Madison right so anyway I think
people were just clapping if they
recognize the names it seems to I mean
if you're gonna go to look at that by
the way imagine that people are sitting
it's eating at Kate it's just crazy
I guess if you go to this you might clap
just like hey I know who he's talking
about I know what's going on here let's
refresh here okay seems like we still
have a little bit of time before this
starts so anyway absolutely ridiculous
July 3rd and July 4th speeches by Donald
Trump completely exhausting to watch
them and to have to parse through them
let's see here Diane marzo knee says hey
David loved the show and welcome back
please send Tucson Arizona your thoughts
and rain our beautiful Santa Catalina
Mountains are on fire yeah I mean it's
what's going on in Arizona is absolutely
horrifying
let's take whoa hold on a second
vacation pictures popping up out of
nowhere Arizona has passed there hundred
thousandth case yeah so this is not the
type of curve that you want certainly
now deaths are
starting to spike but we're still gonna
need a little more time before we know
exactly what's going on there so best
best wishes to our friends in Arizona
and I have friends in Tucson and it's
it's very ugly Charlie says David I miss
the wild and crazy hair sad it's gone
yeah I got a haircut I mean it can still
you can still do something with it you
know so actually that's interesting it's
like an arrow pointing in the other
direction Wow look at that I think I've
got like six inches I've actually
sprayed it with something that defies
gravity that is fascinating it's never
done this before
I'll keep it like this for now oh my god
now what's going down this is crazy oh
now we're definitely in trouble my hair
just snagged oh my god
this is going from bad to worse yeah
anyway that's you do what you can I
can't I can only do what I can do Jr
says what does jr. say oh my mouse might
be dying
Jr's says hey here is my decision you
will come and live in my linen closet
then when I need intelligent and
insightful analysis on what I'm looking
at you can come out and break it down
for me I will provide a strawberry plant
okay
yeah there's an idea and thanks to Jodi
Dillon RN say for upgrading their
membership over on YouTube as well also
big THANK YOU to Cobain for subscribing
with twitch prime extremely important
subscription over with twitch prime and
we are now officially in decay Lee
McEnaney is late phase of the press
briefing this sometimes runs 5 minutes
sometimes it runs 45 minutes I guess I
guess we're going to see thanks to
Anthony Rodriguez for the super chat our
friends Sam Dean from Australia checks
in g'day thoughts on the Vietnam Desert
Storm gaffe I didn't see it again I'm
just back and I'm getting myself caught
up with everything that's going on so I
did not did not yet see that but I will
I will look that up let me see if I had
any other clips that I wanted to play
for you guys today from the long time
that I was gone
I may have heard that Mexico this
Mexican state of Sonora
closed their border to Americans it's
just too dangerous to have Americans
over there were carrying coronavirus at
crazy rates especially in Arizona
they're so Americans are no longer
allowed to cross over into Sonora for
the time being
oh yeah so Trump did do the testing line
again I'll play it for you this was a
fourth of July speech but there and then
we got hit by the virus that came from
China by the way imagine clapping just
at recognizing the geographical origins
of the virus like Spain dealt with it
coming from China and so did we and so
did newzealand it came from China for
everybody but the other countries seem
to somehow be able to deal with it it
didn't excuse them of dealing with it
and we've made a lot of progress our
strategy is moving along well it goes
out in one area and rears back its ugly
face in another area right but we've
learned a lot we've learned how to put
out the flame yeah we've made
ventilators where there were none by the
tens of thousands to the point that we
have far more than we need and we are
now distributing them to many foreign
countries I like how the countries are
foreign we're not just distributing them
to many countries it's going to foreign
countries not domestic countries as a
gesture of goodwill
likewise testing here we go there were
no tests for a new virus but now we have
tested almost 40 million people by so
doing we show cases 99 percent of which
are totally harmless so of course that's
not true that the infection fatality
rate seems to be about 1 percent but of
course you end up sometimes 15 or 20
percent are the numbers in terms of
people who require hospitalization or
have serious cases
still unclear how many of them end up or
will have long-term health effects as a
result of that so riddled riddled
riddled with lies and continuing to
repeat the same things and doing a lot
of that inhaling in between now does my
mic even pick up my inhale because I'm
wondering if my the gate setting block
like when I go like this can you guys
hear it is that audible on mic
nobody knows okay it is okay very good
yeah so Trump you know what was the one
hydroxy chloroquine there's that
interjection you guys can hear it very
well okay good excellent anyway so the
I'm that's enough with the Trump
speeches because I have so much on them
in today's podcast and on the on the
YouTube clip so I'm gonna kind of put up
put a thumb in that for a moment Robert
havens says aside from calling it a hoax
what do you think our president will do
about bounty' gate this president cares
more about monuments than the military I
think that that's it on Russian bounties
Trump just calls it a hoax and that's it
we're not gonna hear and essentially
anything else about it and that's that
that's that's I think it's all going to
be and I don't even know that honestly
because of everything that's going on I
don't know that Trump will be forced to
say more there are people who believe
it's a hoax because Trump said it and
then there are people who I mean either
way they're not voting for Trump so I
doubt that there's gonna be that much
more of it to be perfectly frank okay
let me take a brief moment to tell you
guys about something really horrible
that happened over the weekend it was a
beautiful weekend in many many ways but
last year on the 4th of July in fact we
ran a gigantic membership special we I
think we discounted memberships to like
20 bucks for the year or something like
that and we had hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of people just signing up
it was crazy this is July 4 2019 and all
of those people's memberships were set
to renew this July 4th and because of
the virus I got some of the saddest
emails
hundreds of people who said I can't
afford to renew this year because of
what's going on with the virus so sadly
over the fourth of July weekend as we
were you know taking some time off we
had the biggest loss of memberships in
48 hours so if you are in a position
where you can afford a couple bucks a
month I would love for you to come in
and grab a membership on my website at
join pakman.com you can take advantage
of that same discount if you use that
code 2020 now a memberships 20 bucks for
the entire year if you pay monthly it is
you can also do it monthly I think it's
like a dollar actually I think it's like
a dollar 80 a month if you do it for the
year or two bucks a month it was not a
good fourth of July in that sense and I
understand what's going on I've always
said this show is for everybody we're
doing it we're doing the streams the
podcast all of that stuff by the way the
podcast up twenty percent
month-over-month being on Joe Rogan's
show really really helped us but it was
the the absolute worst 48 hour period in
terms of memberships and we know why I
mean look at what's going on with the
economy Trump brags about we created
four million jobs no you didn't you got
four of the 46 million you lost back ok
that let's let's be honest about what's
going on so I get it and the show will
continue to be here and all the content
other than the bonus show will be
available to everybody but if you are in
the bucket of folks who can afford a
dollar 80 a month consider going to join
pakman.com that coupon code is optional
but available saves you 66% I will thank
every single one of you who signs up
during the stream and if we get to 25 as
you see we're at one right after the
stream I will go out and film the
definitive full urban garden tour I was
away for 10 days what I saw out there
when I got back the sensors would have a
field day with what I saw I will expose
my cukes and cherries to everybody all
right cherry tomatoes I'm talking about
of course in cucumbers like the plant if
we get to 25 new members so very very
exciting stuff going on as we wait here
for Kaylee nak and Annie let's see what
else we've got oh I have a few other
super chats here Jason Quinlan says good
luck USA you're going to need it with
this clown in charge from Wales yeah
hopefully he doesn't last too much
longer I think is the gist of it people
asking if the chess tournament is
tomorrow night
no the chess tournament is next Tuesday
we have 21 people registered right now I
am one of them you can register at david
pakman.com slash chess it's completely
and totally free players right now
ranging in rating from 21:52 all the way
to 909 which is great we want players of
all skill levels some of you by the way
may find it interesting that's oh I'm
just it might be interesting to you that
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura followed me
on Twitter two days ago sorry I froze
there some of you may find that
interesting
I was buffering there for a second that
is something that I found extremely
compelling and some other people may may
as well okay let's see here I want to
say thanks to Matthias Germany who says
via super chat your energy level is
exploding after vacation I am so well
rested you know I was as I mentioned to
folks I my girlfriend and I we were
scheduled to go to Europe in June
obviously that was would have been crazy
we're not even allowed in and we took
the medical advice of professionals like
dr. Mike who is a youtube doctor who
says the safest trips right now are just
trips where you drive somewhere and you
stay within your own state here in
Massachusetts we are blessed with so
many great places to go you've got the
north of Boston areas like Marblehead
and Rockport and etc you can go south
and out into Cape Cod whether you know
it's the Hyannisport area Yarmouth and
you've got East them and Dennis and you
keep going up up the Cape until you
eventually get to the tip as we call it
up
Cape I think it's called where you've
got South Wellfleet Wellfleet Truro
North Truro and Provincetown beautiful
beautiful places then you've got
Martha's Vineyard
you've got Nantucket and so I was in
Martha's Vineyard and I just I I did a
lot of sleeping did a lot of nothing
read a couple books and it was great did
not I don't have a bike rack on my car
so I was not able to bring my bike which
was sad but I posted a bunch of pictures
from the trip on my Instagram and as you
can see here look there's no one around
me I'm completely by myself Here I am on
the beach and Here I am you know near
some trees and Here I am on another
beach and Here I am just with a boat I'm
just completely by myself
and it was extremely safe but yeah I was
I've completely replenished my energy
and now we've got a full week with
interviews and just so much crazy stuff
okay oh wow we have some memberships
coming in the member the website can
barely hold it oh my god there's 55
people right now on the website
considering memberships let me thank
some of them this is crazy
Henk van Loire is new member number two
today Justin York is new member number
three
Stefan Way is new member number four
Brian Brizendine you're number five Pat
les Meister is number six
Jonathan Cali is number seven let's see
who else we've got here Jim McClure Jim
McClure great Jim McClure is number
eight Steven Benelli not bonel Steven
Benelli is number nine today Lauren
Morris is number 10 Andrew Ball is
number 11 beautiful number Jason Butler
is number 12 that we're blowing this
right out of the water Nigel Kohler
oh my god I just took myself
screen didn't I that was crazy work but
if you missed some I'm up to Sherry
flemeth's sherry lemons is number 16 all
going wrong
Craig Warner is new member number 17
today Michelle Phillips is number 18
Salomon booth is number 19
Sharon Saracino prosser is number 20 my
goodness okay and I think I am now at
least tentatively caught up we've only
had two major streaming errors today
which i think isn't bad for jazz
feedback yeah
okay that last one was a joke that one I
knew I did on purpose you didn't miss
anything on that one okay
also big thank yous over on twitch too
high kudos
Clayton B Hyuk rocks the Freak and
magical uniformed fart
yes very professional who is number a
new subscriber 519 over on twitch my
goodness things are just out of control
today okay Okoye oh madrid and anna
wintour have grabbed youtube memberships
nick de gamer says used stimulus check
for membership to spite trump Thank You
Nick as long as you didn't need the
money for something else I don't want
anyone's last dollar do you understand
what I'm saying right the show is here
okay enjoy it it's for everybody don't
need anybody's last dollar but I
appreciate that
Evan field says here we go propaganda
Barbie Cheers David I call it evil
Christian Barbie that's my name
Kyle Engel has subscribed Rowdies says
thoughts on Kanye for president love you
David here's my thought on Kanye for
president black folks are not going to
vote for Kanye merely because he's black
we've seen that time and again we have
polling that is very clear where black
voters don't seem to prefer Kamala
Harris for example so I think the idea
that black voters are going to rush to
Kanye is a pretty pretty dumb idea I
don't
as of right now I don't even see myself
really talking very much see what's
going on here talking very much about
the Kanye thing honestly I don't even
know if it's real like is he's not
actually filed to run I don't even know
that it's it's worth taking seriously
thanks to flag burner and Lauren Otto
for the twitch prime subscriptions I
appreciate that we may be about to hit
our goal of 25 members which means I'm
going to be doing a garden tour after
today's stream uh let's see who did I
miss before where did I leave off okay
Troy Werth is new member number 21
Kenneth Peterson is number 22
Calvin Boone is number 23
Phillip Kelly is number 24 and James
Cook Captain James Cook is number 25 so
there will be I'll film the garden tour
right when we're done with today's
stream but let's keep it going we also
have Mike Armitage who is number 26
today Aaron McClay is number 27
Jennifer trailer number 28 Diego Serna
is new member 29 Brad Francis is new
member number 30
also Nicholas Gonzalez is number 31 and
Linda Benki is number 32 appreciate that
very very much thank you so much for the
support and no no I have no update
people wondering why we have not seen
Kaylee maca nany come out yet you all
know why because she doesn't respect
your time or my time or anyone's time
that's the reason it's always like this
okay other super chats coming in
Congress just announced the two-week
recess says Ian's money Miller yep why
not right I mean nothing's going on
Chris are says do you think we will have
the same day we will have same day kovat
19 tests my understanding is we already
have same-day kovat 19 tests in some
places that's not always the methodology
but I believe we already do have that
Marika says how do you believe Magon
annie has done her job from a trump
Republican perspective like how do you
defend the undefendable Oh Trump is
thinks she's doing a great job and you
know one of the things are terrific work
offs where she has these things which
are clearly there she's clearly planning
on it like there will be a question
about something
she'll so start looking at her pages and
then she'll say you know the question
the media really should be asking is
what is your legacy where will you be
when this president has made America
great again and she has the the cross
always where will you be when the
president has made America great again
and with that I leave you to ponder
thanks very much everybody
right these are completely scripted
fraudulent mic drop moments that are
completely cringe-worthy if you have any
connection to you know how people
interact in the real world to be
perfectly frank but the Republicans just
love it
Don Jr who probably now has coronavirus
since his girlfriend has it retweets it
Kaylee's on fire you know all of this
stuff so to answer your question Marika
from their perspective Kayleigh is
tremendous from the perspective of
caring about facts and logic and reason
it's it's very very bad and it's
actually it's representative of just the
major damage that has been done to truth
and reason during this during during
this administration and it will take a
look I did a segment last week called
removing Trump is only step one because
it's going to be bad for a very long
time and it's it's just absolutely
horrifying
okay um see Baker says what are your
thoughts on the Kennedy marquee race you
know I like the idea of Kennedy in a
sense in the debate against Markey
Markey really crushed him and I have
friends working with with uh with
Kennedy and so I don't think he's a bad
guy I just think that the debate made it
clear that the gain from replacing
Markey Markey with Kennedy was not
obvious and you lose seniority at Markey
now is a very senior member of the
Senate if you replace him with Kennedy
you lose that and when committees are so
important it's not clear to me what the
win is from replacing Ed Markey with
Kennedy that that's that's sort of where
I am right now
Evan field says do you have a prediction
on skoda stacks decision nah I I don't
see the point in making any predictions
there it's so hard to know a coil Madrid
has upgraded and says woop woop F Kayne
yes Michelle Phillips and Caylee have
signed up Sean M says David are you
willing to sing songs on cameo no I'm
not gonna do I don't think I'm gonna do
any singing on cameo
anytime soon yeah over the over the
vacation week I let me see here I'm now
I'm bookable on cameo I'm David Pakman
on cameo I got 40 cameo requests during
the vacation week which was crazy
and there's a bunch of like ongoing
inside jokes between friends where like
one friend has me send one thing and
then another friend has me send
something in conflict to the first
friend a lot of fourth of July greetings
a lot of birthday greetings
what else did I get on cameo yeah a
bunch of different stuff but anyway it's
it's fun I've had to turn down a few
because people were trying to get me to
say like white supremacist things which
I'm sure then are gonna get uploaded oh
my God look at what David it's like
obviously I don't know what I'm saying
but I'm being a little more careful
about that because I don't want to uh I
don't want to get involved in that that
could be very very dangerous nonsense to
get involved in hair tearin' hey pare
great to see you now that I'm back how
long do you think Kate keylight Makenna
me will last seems to be very high
replacement rate and I think Trump has
been angry a couple of her since tries
to do the impossible failed love from
Boris specia I think that means Sweden
yeah I I think that she's mostly seen as
doing well right now I think they're
pretty pleased with her crimson Elric
has subscribed for 10 months on Twitch
and says David be well with love and
other Sam Harris appearance yeah I
actually I would like to have Sam Harris
back on the program we had a great
conversation last time that he was on
which was the only time that I've had
him on and I would love to have him back
and I'm gonna talk to Pat about getting
that going thanks also to master mcli V
for the subscription on Twitch with the
message love the pack thank you okay let
me say a few other membership thank-yous
because I really don't want to see
anybody left behind Brad Francis is new
member number 30 oh no sorry
that's not true I thank Brad already
Taylor Lansdale is new member number 33
Valerie McVeigh is new member number 31
or spicy meat Paul not meatball meat
Paul is new member number 35
Channing riser is number 36 kiri
Bermudez is number 37 troy headman is
number 38 and rainbow road's is number
39 stunning stunning turn of events
completely unpredictable and yes if
you're just joining us you've not missed
it Kaleigh maghen annie is running 23
minutes late as of right now
and we will see just how late she is
still confusion about the chess
tournament it is not tomorrow night the
chess tournament is next Tuesday we have
22 people registered right now you can
register for free to play against me and
many other fellow viewers at david
pakman.com slash chess we currently have
22 people registered last time we had
732 the top rated player is over 2,100
can you imagine and ratings all the way
down to the 900 so everybody is welcome
absolutely everybody and Odra Noah I
think I played against rinoa last time
didn't I let's take a look just gonna
take a quick look here for Noah could
have whoa hold on a second let's see if
we look at games
oh no that's weird they've only played
one game and it's the games going on
right now let's just watch they're
playing a game right now
oh very very early in the game I could
have sworn I played against rinoa last
time that's really weird maybe not
though my memory may be may be failing
me also thanks to JC 205 for subscribing
over on Twitch okay let me find a couple
of the other clips I wasn't gonna do
more clips because I figured that by now
this would have started but let me find
a couple of the other clips that I had
for you oh okay yeah so the garbage math
that I predicted just announced in room
what does that mean somebody's in the
room
they did a two-minute warning let me see
if I get any buddies in the room that
would be great
just refresh here okay
Kaylee Mack and Annie live oh here we go
beautiful somebody says there they it's
going to be 30 more minutes in a room I
don't even know what that means
all right it looks like the the seats
are mostly mostly taken so it looks like
we may we may be getting close here very
very good okay here is here here's again
the wait a second this isn't it ah here
we go
nope that's not it either that's the
stream we're watching let me find that
okay
this is the garbage math clip that I'm
trying to play for you we're still
working the King States economy added
almost five million jobs in the month of
June shattering all expectations you
know what's weird jobs and shattering I
don't think have the letter e at the
beginning but when Trump says it it's
jabs and shattering and I thought that
that was more of like a Philly thing I
don't I don't know why Trump talks that
way that's weird I was watching this
morning and the expectations were much
lower than that yeah the stock market is
doing extremely well which means to me
jobs sort of means jobs does the largest
monthly jobs gain in the history of our
country right so the large this is
exactly what I predicted would happen I
had a clip called are you prepared for
the garbage math or don't fall for the
garbage math we lost 46 million jobs we
then recovered four and Trump says I'm
victorious because we've recovered four
it's like if I cut off all ten of your
fingers and then I bring you two back
that you can get reattached I've done
more for you for this from the
standpoint of giving you fingers than
anybody has ever done I've found three
fingers for you but I cut ten of them
off right and so the this is the exact
type of garbage man
that I've been warning people about and
it's like it's exactly as predicted
exactly as predicted um
insane Lane says hey David I'm Canadian
your thoughts on Americans using the
Alaska loophole to come into Canada
illegally and resulting virus spread I
did not know anything about that I'm
interested to learn more about that I
don't know I've not heard of that whoa
another ad now is running that's weird
okay we're gonna get off of that of
highly commercialized stream running ads
in the middle and I think we're about to
get started here Trevor says who would
you prefer Biden take his his VP pick
and why did you get so much blowback for
your tweet about voters preferring
Warren over Howard Harris I don't I
don't really look at my Twitter replies
so I didn't know I got blowback for that
but I have a full clip from last week
explaining exactly why I prefer Warren
and the reason is she's the most
progressive of the people currently
being considered
thanks to 10-gig Nick who says more
beautiful bezos bucks for you with a
twitch Prime subscription and requiem
has also subscribed with twitch prime
also a big thank you to Keith bone well
okay now we're live in multiple rooms
Keith bone who is new member number
forty today very much appreciate that
Keith Mars Ella buffered is new member
number forty-one and Kathy Donlan is
number forty-two gibreel Lomax is number
forty-three and also oh that's it okay
we may actually hit fifty new members
today that's not happened during a
stream in a really really long time and
I've already committed to doing a tour
of my garden I'll go out and film it
right after we're done here that's gonna
be amazing
that'll be on my Instagram of course how
long do I expect kalium so typically
these have been very very short very
often the full briefing including
questions is under 25 minutes there was
once where I believe it was like 19
minutes so these have been very short
sometimes Kaylee will only speak for
like 90 seconds or 120 seconds and then
just take questions and typically the
questions aren't answered at some point
someone in the back of the room usually
from Oh a n will ask like a completely
bogus softball question which even
Cayley sometimes seems to misunderstand
but realizes like oh this is a softball
so I can get away with stuff all right
here we go let's see what we got today
right hello everyone over the holiday
weekend President Trump delivered two
defining unifying and patriotic speeches
which drew widespread praise by those
who cherish our values honor our history
and seek to advance policies that lift
up all America lies straight out of the
gate the president outlined a vision for
the future president outlined a vision
for stronger and safer communities
coming out hi
president Trump said after all what do
we want we want to strong military great
education housing low taxes law and
order he went on to say we want safety
we want equal justice we want religious
liberty we want faith and family and
living in the great communities and
happy communities and safe communities
and we want great jobs and we want to be
respected by the rest of the world not
taken advantage of went on to say we
should all want the same thing how can
it be any different than those things
right this message is now more important
and more timely than ever yes radical
left-wing mobs we don't tear down our
monuments and our memorials pay
attention to this everyone from George
Washington to Abraham Lincoln to
Frederick Douglass and even Gandhi comes
guided moves use a gum indeed the police
seek to leave our communities more
vulnerable than ever
case in point this weekend alone in New
York there were 44 shootings with 11
killed yeah big cities have shootings we
know that part of the problem is too
many guns
this is their new thing they've lost on
virus they've lost on economy they've
lost on police brutality so their new
thing is to pretend that there is some
kind of violent anarchist Marxist mob
Trump even using the word Marxist over
the weekend
name one prominent Marxist in a position
of power right now that Trump is
fighting against I'm not talking about
some BLM organizer who says they're a
Marxist okay that's not somebody in a
position of power who are the Marxists
he's fighting one family and one nation
we will teach our children to cherish
and adore their country so they can
build its future this vision is not a
culture war as the media seeks to
falsely proclaim it's an embrace of our
American family our values our freedom
and our future and with that I'll take
questions so I think you're referring to
a tweet this morning is that right well
I think your mischaracterizing the tweet
the tweet was aimed at pointing out that
the FBI report of the alleged hate crime
at NASCAR concluded that the garage-door
pool which had been there since last
fall was obviously not targeted at a
specific individual because in fact it
was a garage pool and in fact it was
there since last fall long before these
43 teams arrived and it was concluded by
the FBI that this was quote not an
intentional racist act my question is
why is the president so supportive of
flying the Confederate flag the
president never said that again you're
taking his tweet completely out of
context the president said that NASCAR
saw bad ratings because they took down
the Confederate flag banned the
Confederate flag does he believe NASCAR
should fly the Confederate flag and why
don't they fly here
the whole point of the tweet was to note
the incident the alleged hate crime that
it in fact was not a hate crime at the
very end the ban on the flag was
mentioned in the broader context of the
fact that he rejects this notion that
somehow NASCAR men and women who go to
these sporting events our race it's bad
for Trump for this to continue being an
issue because he's doing nothing and
just asking questions about flags this
is very bad for Trump and I love it
prime it was a complete indictment of
the media's rush to judgment once again
calling this a hate crime when the FBI
completely dismissed them
some of the president's comments this
weekend the president said that 99% of
coronavirus cases are totally harmless
and we like members of the White House
to run a virus task force agree with
that statement so what the president was
pointing to and I'm glad you brought it
up was a factual statement one that is
rooted in science and one that wasn't
pointing out the fact that mortality in
this country is very low and I have two
charts that will pull up to illustrate
that the first chart is the case
fatality rates in the United States and
as you can see the mortality rate has
gone like this the case fatality rate
and also in the second chart you'll see
hopefully they have it up behind me but
the Cates rates fatality rate in this
country visa vie other European
countries is much lower than let's say
France and Italy and what that speaks to
is the great work of this administration
with therapeutics and rum des aveer it
actually has nothing to do with the
administration at all so if you don't
die is it not harmless the president was
noting the fact that the vast majority
of Americans who contract Crona virus
will come out on the other side of this
of course he takes us very seriously of
course no one wants to see anyone in
this country contract Ovid which is why
the administration is concerned to make
sure to imagine claiming that three
weeks on a ventilator is harmless as
long as you survive right what is the
president's position does he think
NASCAR made a mistake by banning the
Confederate flag so he said he I spoke
to him this morning about this and he
said he was not making a judgment one
way or the other
why not the intent of this guy was to
stand up I'll make a judgement it should
be banned it's a symbol of hate that's
it just say it right just just make a
judgement it's okay make a judgement to
call something a hate crime when in fact
the FBI report concluded this was not an
intentional racist act and it very much
mirrors other times when there have been
a rush to judgment let's say with the
Covington boys or let's drill down on
the Confederate flag does he think it
was a mistake
for NASCAR to beautiful the president
said he wasn't making a judgment one way
or the other you're focusing on one word
at the very bottom of a tweet that's
completely taking out of context and
neglecting the complete rush to judgment
our ratings are down because they fans
the flag that's what he said and the
president was noting the fact that in
aggregate this notion that NASCAR men
and women who have gone and who are
being demeaned and called racist and
being accused in some venues of
committing a hate crime and against your
individual supporters should not take
the flag to trump rally to see consider
Fanning the Confederate flag from Trump
Trump rallies all flags that are not
official campaign gear are banned yes
why is it bubble is the responsibility
to apologize for an investigation into a
news that he didn't report and he never
even saw it was NASCAR that found this
that reported this and even the FBI
referred to it as a news even if they
said it wasn't a specific crime against
mr. Wallace why is the further than even
suggesting the mr. Wallace should
apologize well FBI as I noted concluded
that this was not a hate crime and he
believes it go a long way if Bobbitt
came out and acknowledged that as well
this which she seems more flustered
today than normal intentional one of
these days so one of the things that one
of this is where the president comes
from and this is where the president
stands and he actually hinted at this in
his July fourth speech to those in the
media who falsely and be able to label
their opponents as a racist who condemn
patriotic citizens who offer a clear and
truthful defense of American unity we
want to clear and faithful defense of
American history and unity and when you
level false charges right you not only
slander me you slander the American
people he believes the American people
are in the allegations and the rush to
judgment was just
smaller oh my god in the bubble Wallace
case and with the Covington Catholic
boys we shouldn't be so quick to jump on
to understand that it none of those
other things have anything to do with
Trump's opinion of the Confederate flag
she's distorting and conflating why was
that allowed to happen did she have
contact with the President on the trip
back and has the president yes the
president is tested constantly has
tested negative and those around him are
tested as well but why was the original
question is why was she allowed to fly
that on Air Force One with the president
when it was known that she had had
contact with somebody who opposed it
positive for the virus yeah I'd have to
refer you to Secret Service on that but
I'll tell you this they take the
president's health very seriously they
would never put him in a situation that
would put him in harm's way
never
on executive orders the president has
set a pretty brisk pace on those this
year and as a candidate he had been
critical like President Obama's use of
executive order hearing my stuff but he
seems to have really stepped up the pace
on these and I wanted to ask you know
what does he find what is the strategy
behind issuing more than one oh there's
no so far this year and I know he's
getting ready to issue more in the
coming weeks
well he will use the powers and his
executive toolkit to further the agenda
of the American people that's his intent
with these executive orders and I would
just note that with regard to the daca
decision the Supreme Court has suggested
he is pretty wide discretion to act yes
this is the president worried at all
that by downplaying the severity of the
virus that it will lead Americans to be
less careful no he's not downplaying the
president and downplaying the severity
of the virus what the president's noting
is that at the height of this pandemic
we were at 2,500 deaths per day we are
now at a place where on July 4th there
were 254 that's a tenfold decrease to
expect
I'm 209 individuals down 23% from last
Sunday and the lowest Sunday since March
28th the president's made clear we
grieve when just one life is lost but he
wants to note the progress that we've
made in treating this very serious virus
when we have there peuta convalescent
plasma room desk that's his own
convalescent plasma in particular was
spearheaded by this administration he's
used he's pulled down bureaucracy and
allowed us to get to a place where we
can have this declining mortality rate
just to follow
you were saying that we're taking the
tweet out of context but this is what he
tweeted he says has that Bubba Wallace
apologized to all those great NASCAR
drivers and officials who came to his
aid stood by his side and we're willing
to sacrifice everything for him only to
find out that the whole thing was just
another hoax that and flag decision has
caused lowest ratings ever how how are
we misinterpreting that I've explained
to you this is I guess the fourth
attempt but we'll try it again
look quite an aggregate what he was
pointing out is this rush to judgment to
immediately say that there is a hate
crime as happened in this case as happen
with Jessie small that has happened with
the Covington Catholic boys in an
aggregate those actions made it seem
like Nascar men and women were racist
individuals who were roving around and
engaging in a hate crime
the president's intent was to say no
mostly white people are good
hard-working people should not have this
rush to judge understand how they
distort the American people are good
hard-working people the questions about
Trump's opinion about flags is why
should mr. Wallace have to apologize for
that when his whole team all these
colleagues came around him to show
support yeah that's the best of America
is coming around when the media alleged
to hate crime on coming around and
supporting Bubba Wallace as they should
have done I think that shows how loving
NASCAR fans are that fellow drivers but
I think it's important that loving fans
with Confederate flags why is it no hate
crime the FBI concluded that time and
President Trump was merely saying that
mr. Wallace should agree with that
consensus yes Mario that's what we're
trying to ask you
Hey ladies why should I I'm not going to
answer a question at this rate the other
people waiting is genius because if they
go on to their question at short
circuits that now he's going NASCAR for
removing the Confederate flag
particularly given the history of that
flag the symbol that it has for
african-americans and also what it
represents in terms of just the the
treasonous accident insurrection against
the Republic
so I praise them for takes great offense
when Americans are knee-jerk reaction
summed up as racist in terms of picture
being painted here in this instant
incident I seem to be that there was
that suggestion there when in fact what
we're seeing across the nation is this
vast canceled culture with tear down
arguments we're going to check out my
video last week on canceled culture by
the way George Washington we're going to
tear down Lincoln and it's really quite
appalling what we've seen happen across
the country and on the president wants
no part in canceled culture he wants no
part and the tearing down into facing a
mathias baldwin and abolitionist
philadelphia Civil War soldiers John
Greenleaf Whittier vandalized an
abolitionist he wants no part in this
notice that this has nothing to do with
Mario's question Americans honey stands
firmly on the side of preserving our
history yes
he's not I said from the very top of his
briefing he is not given it in the gym
one way or the other on that I just
spoke to him this morning he should give
an opinion about the flag why is he the
president never used those words those
are the words of a reporter not that of
the President of the United States yes
Phil the president argued on Friday and
then again on Saturday that many of the
problems the country faces stem from
quote extreme ink doctrine ation and
bias here we got in the education system
if that's the case is he working with
secretary DeVos to address what he sees
absolutely major problem oh yeah what
steps is he taking to uncheck this one
could you give us an example yeah I have
to inquire about that about specific
steps that he's taken and I'm not aware
we had these conversations with
secretary DeVos but I will certainly
follow up look we've got a real problem
in this country we do when you have
rioters who I've listed off some of the
examples of abolitionists there seems to
be zero understanding of history when
you're defacing the statue of Matthias
Baldwin not the question stop reading
those names Kelly there seems to be a
lack of understanding and historical
knowledge when the Armenian Genocide
memorial remembering victims of all
crimes against humanity including
slavery is vandalized other seems to be
a lack of understanding of history when
the first responders sculpture is
damaged when the Polish war hero statue
- world war one Memorial the Lincoln
Memorial the World War Two memorial and
absolutely the Robert Gould Shaw and the
54th regiment Washington Memorial oh
yeah african-american soldiers who
fought values that's what this is really
about damaged in Boston we need to have
a better historical understanding and
I'll follow up with you about specific
conversations
question about mask the president has
equivocated on the issue of masks and we
know that a number of Republicans are
starting to say that it's the most
single most important thing that
Americans can do to protect each other
what does the president's message to
Americans who hear those messages and
say that they simply don't want to wear
a mask the president was very clear last
week that if he were in a situation
where he wasn't tested daily and he was
in close proximity and unable to social
distance that he would wear a mask so he
has made that clear on his rally this
weekend in New Hampshire master not only
handed out but they are recommended say
first off point of fact Bubba Wallace
did not make any kind of false report
and I'm wondering in general why the
president thinks that issue is worth his
time and focused you know in the midst
of a deadly pet because he's losing on
every other issue opinion on the
Confederate flag why can't this White
House unambiguously state whether or not
it supports displays of the Confederate
flag because it needs those supporters
of the flag to support him yeah I said
that you know he was his tweet was not
to indicate approval or disapproval of
that particular problem car it was an
aggregate that's the blood to stand
against the rush to judgment to call
something a hate crime before the facts
were out when clearly the me and now
tell us his position on the flag barely
I never said that perhaps one of the
reporters said that but I certainly did
not but he believes that we should be at
the truth matters and that the truth was
the FBI did a thorough investigation and
what was concluded that there was no
hate crime here and we should all be
grateful for questions about the flag
not the hate crime fans came together
and a great display of American unity
around a mr. Wallace but then we should
also be equally unequivocal about the
truth of this situation here and that
most Americans are great hard-working
people
nobody denied that had questions about
the flag during the pandemic yes
he's focused on two things at once
something we're all capable of doing
look the president has made clear he's
not taking a position one way or the
other that's the problem yes yes why not
you heard that last question does the
president support the Cleveland Indians
and the football team here in Washington
considering changing their names I
haven't spoken to the President on that
list I played for you earlier so I don't
know exactly who came up with that list
I can ask about it but it's a pretty
extraordinary list of people I think we
can all agree on the fact that great
American heroes are people like Harriet
Tubman and Frederick Douglass on a
Booker T Washington was Trump getting in
the way of putting Harriet Tubman on the
$20 bill but now he wants a statue over
Anthony and Dewey Graham so I think we
can all Premier League ran oh my god
American protection program extension
over the weekend
there's 132 billion dollars in the pot
what does the president think that that
lunch should be used for if it's still
there after August 8th and then in a
cares for specifically what could be
there to help small businesses right
yeah so I don't have any update on phase
four I've mentioned that the payroll tax
is something of great interest to the
president because it would help low low
and middle to the extent Trump's ever
shown curiosity about anything he's
interested in the payroll tax with that
small businesses across the country I've
gotten this and we've kept people on
payroll so he's very pleased with the
progress that's been made there in the
continuing functioning of the PPP veto
of a bill then that did not have a
payroll
relief in it yeah I don't want to set
parameters or conditions that'll be up
to the president when the bill arrives
on his desk yes what will be the
criteria to cancel the travel bans
because we know that the bantha are
simply for European countries where the
situation is oh yeah we're not allowed
anywhere so what Trump does is less
relevant actually we're not allowed to
go anyway right now yeah so what is the
criteria yeah so I don't have specific
criteria to give you I'd have to refer
you to the State Department and
secretary Pompeo and his remarks on the
topic during his last press conferences
where we currently stand but president
Trump in the administration have taken
bold decisive and frequent action to
secure our homeland but a big part of
that has been these travel restrictions
and we're working with countries around
the world that we hope to have a day
where energy and international travel is
open but right now this is about putting
America rapping and I want to say this I
prepare for the scripted walk off we
were talking about here but the u.s. is
too bad how do you think
were looking at the ad since we know I
think the world is looking at us as a
leader and Cove in nineteen because the
chart I showed you where you have
mortality rate and Italy and UK up here
and across Europe and you have the
United States I'm at a low I'm not even
gonna insult you guys by refuting these
dumb lies I respect my audience too much
you all know this is horseshit on
ventilators and having excessive
insulators that we were able to deploy
around the world and help other
countries so that's what I would have to
say ANCOVA and finally I didn't with
this you know I was asked here it is
probably twelve questions about the
Confederate flag yeah this president
focused on action and I'm a little
dismayed that I didn't receive one
question on the deaths that we got in
this country this weekend I didn't
receive one question if they have
nothing to do with Trump doubling for
the third straight week and over the
last seven days shooting skyrocket by a
hundred forty two percent not one quest
group did walk I didn't received one
question about five children who were
killed and I'll leave you with this
remark by a dad group the heart a dad of
an eight-year-old lost in Atlanta this
weekend they say black lives matters you
killed a child she didn't do nothing to
nobody was his quote we need to be
focused on securing our streets making
sure no lives are lost because all black
lives matter that of David Doran and
that of this eight-year-old girl thank
you wow what a mic drop moment she
really owned the blib tarde press right
I mean wow wow just this one went
particularly poorly particularly poorly
I they're up against the wall guys
they're up against the wall in a way
we've not seen I mean it's like the guys
losing every poll Republican strategists
are saying Michigan's gone just forget
about Michigan Wisconsin soon going to
be gone and you know she asks all these
she complains all these questions are
about mass it's like well this is the
big topic Trump is choosing because he's
losing on the virus and he's losing on
the economy and his speeches are insane
and he's glitching and sweating and
white knuckling the lectern so he's
tweeting about the flag
so obviously the question is is he for
the flag or is he again
the Confederate flag uh NAB solutely
unbelievable unbelievable if you're
watching on Twitch
remember to hit that follow button it's
free and that way you'll be notified
when I go live in the future of course
if you're watching on YouTube please
make sure you hit the subscribe button
there it's all free and you'll be
notified when I go live it's great to be
back from vacation there will be much
live plenty live this week and I do want
to remind you that next Tuesday we are
going to be doing the third David Pakman
show chess tournament it is open to all
you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash chess and right now we have 29
people registered we had 732 people play
last time we did it this is going to be
the third monthly chess tournament and
you can find out more at david
pakman.com slash chess and as I promised
earlier because we did get to 25 members
we actually got to 43 I am going to go
out and film the full urban garden tour
I'm going to upload it to my Instagram
probably in about a 45 or 60 minutes so
I'm gonna go ahead and do that I'll see
all of you very very soon and as always
thank you so much for joining me
you